Melissa de la Cruz,
Sandhya Menon, Nicola Yoon,
Abby McGanney Nolan (mod)
>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Abby McGanney Nolan:
Hey everyone.
Welcome to the Library of
Congress National Book Festival.
My name is Abby Nolan and
I review children's books
for the Washington Post which
has been a charter sponsor
of the festival.
We want to thank the Co-Chairman
of the festival, David Rubenstein
and the many National
Book Festival sponsors
who have made this event possible.
If you would like to help support
the festival with a donation,
you can find that information
in your program.
So before we start with the panel
discussion about falling in love,
or rather books about
people falling in love,
I want to introduce our
three amazing authors.
There will be time for questions
from the audience and everyone
who asks a question will
be filmed for the archives
and could appear on
a later broadcast.
So first, Melissa de la Cruz
is the bestselling author
of many well-loved novels.
These include several series
such as the Blue Blood Series
which Booklist called "Famed
and fabulous" "The Isle
of the Lost" Descendant Series, and
the "Witches of East End Series",
as well as, standalone novels
like "Fresh off the Boat"
and "Something In Between."
Melissa's latest book is
"Alex and Eliza" a love story
which is inspired by her daughter's
interest in Elizabeth Schuyler
after they saw the
musical "Hamilton."
Melissa was born in the
Philippines, moved to San Francisco
when was twelve and now lives with
her family in southern California.
[ Applause ]
>> Melissa de la Cruz: That's me.
>> Abby McGanney Nolan: Next
we have Nicola Yoon who grew
up in Jamaica and Brooklyn,
New York.
She has written two
bestselling books
about teenagers falling in love.
The first, "Everything, Everything"
has won lots of acclaim and has been
as you probably know
made into a movie.
Her latest novel is called
"The Sun Is Also a Star"
which follows two New York City
high school students seniors
and mostly takes place in the
course of one very eventful day.
Nicola lives in Los
Angeles with her family.
[ Applause ]
And at the end we have
Sandhya Menon.
She was born and raised in
India and some of her love
for Hollywood movies
can be discerned
in her first novel
"When Dimple Met Rishi."
It is also a bestselling novel
and it follows two Indian-American
teens whose parents conspire
to arrange their marriage.
Sandhya lives in Colorado
with her family and pets,
and her next book is due next year.
So, thank you.
[ Applause ]
So, where to begin?
I was struck by the fact that
all three of the young women
in your newest books, seemed not at
all interested in falling in love
at the start of their stories.
In "The Sun Is Also a Star" Natasha
is going to be deported that night
to Jamaica and is laser
focused on finding a lawyer
who can help them stay
in the United States.
At the beginning of "Alex and
Eliza", Elizabeth Schuyler does not,
doesn't want to put on a fancy
gown she's supposed to wear
and is much more concerned with the
war that's going on around them,
and in "When Dimple Met
Rishi" Dimple is obsessed
with creating her own app.
She wants to help people deal
with serious medical issues;
wants to make a difference
in the world
and here comes this
boy who distracts her.
So, did you all start out with this
kind of character with this scenario
or did that develop as you
were writing the books?
>> Melissa de la Cruz:
Who wants to take it?
You know, I was really interested
in Elizabeth Schuyler as a character
and it was interesting to me
that I was interested in her
because I'm usually drawn
to the more kind of worldly,
the more gossipy, the more
sophisticated characters.
So I was wondering why wasn't I
writing a book about Angelica who is
so much more the kind of
character that I write, you know,
much more interested in
status and, you know,
kind of furthering her own
kind of vain ambitions,
because I love kind
of those villainess.
Like I cheer for the Baroness
in "Sound of Music", you know,
so you know so that's the kind
of character I always like.
So, I said, "Why am I
so interested in Eliza?"
And I didn't know didn't know
whether it's like the times we are
in now, but I just wanted
to write about somebody
who was a really good
person and I was so drawn
to her the way Alexander Hamilton
wrote about his love for her.
You know, what drew him to
her, you know, and I just felt
like she embodied this
kind of American you know
like really true American
values, you know,
like she was not worldly
in the way Angelica was.
You know, she was not this kind
of flirt who would like come
into a European ballroom.
You know, like she
was very sensible.
She was very practical and
I think in kind of writing
about her character, I wanted to
show that she wanted to be part
of you know the war
effort, you know,
part of like helping the revolution,
like that's what mattered to her.
You know, not falling in love with
a soldier, you know, like she wanted
to be you know somebody who mattered
in her own way and it didn't matter
who she married, so that's
where that came from.
>> Nicola Yoon: Yeah, I mean,
so "The Sun Is Also a Star" is
about a very poetic boy
named Daniel who tries
to convince Natasha who's very
science-minded to fall in love
with him over the course of
twelve hours in New York City
and they only have twelve hours
because her family
is being deported.
And you know, what I really wanted
to talk about in the book is,
you know, the idea that science
and arts are opposed to each other.
Like we always put those things on
the opposite end of the spectrum
and people say that they're
left brain or right brain
or they're good a math or
they're good at English and as
if you couldn't be both, right.
I mean, I think most people
are reasonably good at both,
but we sort of specialize
really young.
And I think a way of looking
at the world is to look at it
from both an artistic perspective
and from a more scientific one
and I think you actually
get a more complete picture
of the world that way.
And in both places are true, like
art and science they're all trying
to get truth but they just
come at it from different ways.
So, given that I wanted
to talk about that
and like I'm really was a big
fan of Carl Sagan and sort
of the way he was able to take
science and bring it down to
like a human level, I just came
up with the passion of Daniel.
So, Daniel is like the boy
who doesn't really
believe in facts, you know.
He's like it's fine.
It's all about love and Natasha
is like very, very science-minded,
right so she is you know, like if
you can't write it down and prove it
and measure it, I don't
want to hear about it.
And I really wanted to see how I
could make these two people come
together and come to the place
where you know the world is made
up of both those things
and your brain,
it's not mind versus
body, it's them together.
It is science and art, I
mean, all if mixed for love.
So I think that's where
the book came from.
>> Sandhya Menon: And when
Dimple; can you guys hear me?
Okay. In "When Dimple Met Rishi"
I was really interested in playing
with the gender stereotypes
and kind of reversing them
where we always hear that girls are
really interested in falling in love
and getting married and
having that happily ever after
and boys are more interested in
independence and their career.
So I wanted to flip that and have
the girl be really independent
career minded and wanted nothing
to do with love and the boy
to be really a traditionalist
and a huge, soft romantic
and so that's kind of where
Dimple gets her fierceness from.
>> Abby McGanney Nolan:
That's great.
Um, to look at the plots
of these novels it seems
like you all are getting
them to know each other,
the two main characters, as
they find out what's important
to each other and what their sense
of humor is, and at the same time,
you're putting obstacles in
their way, lost cell phones,
misunderstandings, family
battles, deportation.
How do you manage these
waring objectives?
Do you have to plot it out or
how do you manage that narrative?
>> Nicola Yoon: Yeah, you know, so
"Sun Is Also a Star" takes place
over twelve hours in New York, and
when I had the idea I thought, "Oh,
this is going to be good."
And then what you realize is
that it's twelve hours, right,
and you have to manage
your day, right.
Like what is the average walking
speed of the teenage couple?
Like what are the train
schedules in New York City
and how long does it take to get
from this place to that place?
And I have a Excel spreadsheet
that maps it all out,
because the first draft I
think I had twenty hours.
It was just like, that
does not work.
They cannot walk that fast
unless they fly and they
like literally lift the weight
with their hands and, so yeah,
I mean it's like some of
that stuff is just practical
like seriously Google
maps was my friend,
because it has train schedules
on there now and they have videos
and you can sort of
fly through New York
and see the different
neighborhoods and map the,
you know, the time it takes.
So some of that is just purely
practical get your spreadsheet
out and do some math.
>> Melissa de la Cruz: I
wanted to write like a "Pride
and Prejudice" style conflict into
my story, because you know the story
of Alex and Eliza seemed
like such a fairytale.
That, you know, this penniless,
nameless orphan boy who falls
in love with basically a
rich American princess.
So, I thought about you know what do
families with fortune usually want.
They want their daughters to marry
men from other similarly landed and,
you know, very prestigious
families and that's her family.
Her mom, Catherine
Rensselaer was the daughter
of the richest family in New York.
I mean, they basically
owned the entire colony
and then her father was, you know,
General Philip Schuyler who came
from another really
landed prestigious family
and he was a general in
the Continental Army.
And so I wanted to write about how,
you know, her family was very weary
of you know this kind of, this guy
who came from nowhere, you know,
asking for their daughter's
hand and you know, of course,
mom you know moms always a little
bit a villain wanting you know a
very rich marriage.
So, that's where the
conflict came from.
So, I outline and always outline
my stories, but a lot of the things
like I knew I wanted
to start with the ball.
I knew I wanted to have, you
know, a little bit of conflict.
I wanted to show the war and
then I wanted to show, you know,
this kind of "Pride and
Prejudice" storyline.
So, yeah a lot of is
a lot of planning.
>> Sandhya Menon: Similarly, in
"When Dimple Met Rishi" I knew
from the beginning that there
would be a lot of obstacles
with both Dimple and
Rishi and their parents,
and like familial expectations.
And so, that was something I
thought about from the beginning,
but also as I was writing,
what evolved more was
like this whole question of being
Indian-American and belonging
to two cultures and which parts
of which culture do I want accept
and which parts don't work
for me and what does that mean
when it comes to my family.
So that kind of evolved as I wrote.
>> Abby McGanney Nolan: I
also wanted to ask you all
about this idea of
hopeless romantic.
I think Nicola you mentioned
you talked about yourself
as a hopeless romantic, but it seems
hopeful a romantic and I also wanted
to ask about destiny and kismet
and they all kind of come
up in your books and how did
you think through that theme?
>> Nicola Yoon: Yeah, I mean I
always say I'm a hopeless romantic,
but you know, I think that
as a culture we tend to talk
down about love, right, and
especially when we talk about books.
And falling in love, but this
is my mantra in life, right,
everything is about love,
like no matter like,
don't let people tell
you it's not right.
If it's love with your work or if
it's love of heart, or your family,
or your kids, or yourself, or
another person in a romantic way,
everything is about love.
It's the thing that everyone
wants or they're recovering from
or they're trying to get.
And so, you know, I
always write about it.
I particularly love a romantic
book because I love the idea
of people falling in love with
each other's ideas of the world
and usually people start
out thinking that they're
so different than someone else.
In "Sun Is Also a Star" you have
like the Korean American boy
and this Jamaican immigrant
and they start out thinking
that they couldn't possibly have
anything in common and I married
to someone who's American but of
Korean descent and I have more
in common with him than I've ever
had with anyone in my whole life.
And like that includes my like
you know Jamaican parents, right,
so I think we tend to think these
things that we're so far apart
and we talk down about
love, but it is the thing
that makes the world go
round, and like I don't care
if anyone thinks that's a cheesy
of a tool goober about it,
but it is the thing that
makes the world go round
and so it is why I write
about it all the time.
>> Sandhya Menon: I also
believe in the power of love.
Like I think that looking down on
romance is pretty common and also
like first love or teen
romance, like people are like oh
that will never last, and I ended up
marrying my high school sweetheart,
so I think I'm like especially
you know I take offense
to that, because it did work out.
But I love this idea of like
kismet and that comes up a lot
in "When Dimple Met Rishi" and
just the idea of like two people
who on the surface seem to be
poles apart, but they come together
and they find, you know, something
in common because they're just meant
to be and I love that idea,
so that was something I
just love to write about.
>> Melissa de la Cruz: Yeah, no
it was interesting what you said
about how people kind of
denigrate love like even
in the book there's a one scene and
it's interesting as I was looking
at a, you know, kind of Internet
reactions to the book, you know,
they said, "Oh, that
could never happen."
You know, Alexander Hamilton
was a love struck guy.
Oh please.
You know, especially that
scene that's so cheesy
and then the scene is when he
spends an entire night with Eliza
and he comes back to the fort and
he can't remember the password,
like he just can't remember
it because he was so in love.
He was like in the
cloud and, you know,
he just couldn't remember
the password to get back
into the fort, and
that's a real story.
Like that actually happened
and finally the young soldier,
you know, like took pity on him.
Like he knew he was you
know Colonel Hamilton.
He was like yeah get in, you know,
but you know that was a real story
and I think that kind of,
that's what made me interested
in this story like that somebody
that we saw as this genius,
this founding father, the
Secretary of the Treasury, you know,
wrote The Federalist Papers.
He was a guy in love
once and the other reason
that I wrote the story was
because even though they didn't
have a perfect marriage, you know,
we all know he cheated on
her, as my daughter says
"Is the sequel Alex
and Eliza and Maria?"
I'm like, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You know, but because she
forgave him you know and the fact
that she died wearing; he wrote
her a poem when they were courting
and she put it in a necklace and
she died buried with that necklace
and she was the one who
carried on his legacy
who made sure we know about him.
And I think because of her love
for him, I felt like I could write
about them, that it was still a
love that was worthy of writing
about because the other thing
that people talk about is
like oh he was you know an
adulterer, he was unfaithful
and I was like well
why does that takeaway
from this great love that they have?
I mean, he was flawed, you know,
he was human and he made a mistake,
but you know, they, he; she forgave
him and they you know died together
and I just thought it just
made me you know kind of think
about what kinds of love there are
and that to me was just so great
to have that kind of love to
be able to forgive someone.
We're all hopeless romantics here.
>> Abby McGanney Nolan: I was
also impressed by the fact
that all three books take the
perspective of both parties;
both the female and the male and I
was wondering if that was something
that you set out to do all
of you or if that just seemed
like the way to go at some point:?
>> Sandhya Menon: I
definitely set out to do that.
I've never written in dual,
you know, point of view before
and I thought it would be
so fascinating especially
because the characters are so
completely different from each other
for the reader to be able to
see the love story developing
from both their points of view,
because they have completely
different ideas of what love is
and what they want from life and I
just thought it would be really cool
to see how it comes
together at the end.
>> Nicola Yoon: Yeah, I mean
definitely very similar, you know,
Daniel is the poetic one, right,
so he's sort of like pollen to air
and Natasha is very science-minded,
so I wanted to show the different
perspective and them coming
to like the common ground
and it was really fun
to have them experience
the same thing,
but like take a totally
different message from it, right.
Like to be able to just see
it completely differently,
and then sort of fall in
love with the other ways,
by the person's way
of looking at it.
My husband is like this very,
very strange person and I say
that with affection, but I we will
agree on things, but he will come
at it from a completely
out of left field.
"Like, what are you
even talking about?"
And then I was like
"Oh, you're right."
But he just, he gets there
differently and so I wanted to show
that getting there differently
and how that's sort of cool.
>> Melissa de la Cruz: No definitely
and I think because, you know,
we wanted to show this love
story from both sides, right,
it was like I mean Alex was just
as much a character that I cared
about as Eliza and I think the story
would have been a little one-noted
if it was all from
her point of view.
So, I think I liked to show you know
the male perspective and I also,
what's interesting is
like all of the guys
in our books are all the romantic
ones and you know that's even
like with me and husband, like I'm
much more practical and pragmatic
and he's the one who's the
hopeless romantic, you know,
so I kind of like that dynamic.
>> Abby McGanney Nolan: So I
wanted to talk about awkwardness.
These kind of uncomfortable
pauses, awkward moments,
and they seem to be tied into kind
of the sweetness to the characters,
both the men and the young
women and the young men.
And I don't really remember that in
the books that I read growing up,
but it seems you know kind of have
come to the floor with John Green,
and "Eleanor & Park"
and I was wondering
if it's something that
you can speak to?
>> Nicola Yoon: I mean,
awkwardness can be glorious.
>> Melissa de la Cruz: Yeah.
>> Nicola Yoon: It's so
awkward can be so uncomfortable
and like you just, he's so
cute, you're thinking it
and then you're staring, you
don't realize you're staring
and there's something in your teeth.
It's terrible right?
Or like the first kiss isn't
perfect but maybe the second one is.
I mean it's just true, right.
I mean, you just, I god I was
so embarrassing as a teenager.
You have no idea.
I was in love with
like the, high school,
captain of the high school
basketball team, completely in love
and I was, I was not his type.
I was like shy and just you
know read books all the time,
but I just loved him and I called
him on the phone and I was just
like an anonymous admirer; I don't
even know why I'm telling you this,
but it's terrible [brief laughter].
I was like his anonymous admirer
and he liked me on the phone
and then finally I said I'm
going to do the big reveal,
I was like fine I will
be wearing this.
I'll be at the end of the
hallway this day, right?
Yeah, this [multiple speakers].
So, he is there at the end of
the hallway with his friends,
his basketball friend buddies.
I on the other hand, and he
looked at me and he pointed
and laughed and it was the worst.
I'm okay. And thank god,
because that guy is a loser
and I've got the perfect boy for me,
but I mean my awkwardness
is just part of life, right,
and it's a funny story now.
[ Laughter ]
>> Abby McGanney Nolan: Yeah,
and I think you all capture
awkwardness perfect, you know,
kind of exquisitely and it
leads to drama and resolution
and I mean do you really
work on it like every moment?
>> Melissa de la Cruz: Yeah,
I think you know you draw
from your own life, you know, and
there's been so; putting yourself
out there you know when you
told your story I was like,
oh my god I just remembered
so many embarrassing stories.
You know, of like telling
people that I, you know,
"I like you.: Like, "yeah I know."
And it's like, oh!
Like oh dear.
You know, and it's just yeah it's
just part of life of being awkward
and you know and especially
where you're falling
in love you're infatuated,
you're so awkward
because you're so vulnerable.
You know, and I was trying to think
of the stories that I read growing
up and you know there just
weren't a lot of stories
for teenagers I think, so I think
that's why we don't remember
that part of the story,
you know, from the past.
Like it is something maybe we're
bringing in because why it's
so much bigger now and we can tell
longer books and you know kind
of go deeper into the
teen experience.
>> Awkwardness.
>> Melissa de la Cruz: Deeper
into awkwardness definitely.
>> Sandhya Menon: Same thing for me.
I think like I'm naturally a
pretty awkward person and even
when I was a teen I was like, I
was always the one who would trip,
you know, at the most
inopportune time.
You know, going up to get my
diploma and you know that kind
of thing is horrible, and one of
my favorite words is "adorkable:"
And I think like, I think that
captures that so perfectly,
because it so relatable when
people are you know embarrassed
and they immerse themselves
and they still,
they're just putting themselves out
there and they're so vulnerable.
I mean, I think that
absolutely needs to be in,
especially in teen books.
>> Nicola Yoon: Yeah,
because you do make it
out through the other side right?
I mean, like if you have
that awkward moment maybe he
or she is having the awkward
moment too and then it's cute.
>> Exactly.
>> Nicola Yoon: And then you end
up together and have five children.
>> Yeah.
>> Yep.
>> Abby McGanney Nolan:
I'll open it up soon.
I want to just ask a
couple more questions
and I think there are
microphones on different sides.
I don't see them though.
But, in terms of the We
Need Diverse Books Movement,
you all address cultural differences
and in the United States,
as well as, some very serious social
issues amid the love and awkwardness
and I was wondering is it
something that you are thinking
about for future projects
too at this point or,
I know you also had a
novel about deportation.
About a girl who's.
>> Melissa de la Cruz: You know,
it's amazing to me to sit here
and to be in this industry.
I've been a writer for
about twenty years now
and when I was starting out,
you know, the only Asian writer
that I knew was Amy Tan and I would
write my query letters to agents
and to publishers saying like,
I want to be like Amy Tan
because she was the only writer
I knew of color from, you know,
kind of my background;
I'm part Chinese
and to see you know the
growth in the industry
to celebrate the diversity
and the American story,
it's overwhelming really.
It's a, I'm so happy that
we've made so many strides.
I'm hoping we make more.
You know, there's always more to do,
but yeah I mean I stared out writing
about you know, I started with
a book called "The Au Pairs"
and it was with a company called
Alloy and they were a company
that made "Sweet Valley
High" which was one
of my favorite book
series growing up.
And I was like "Oh, my god
I writing Sweet Valley High"
but for a new generation.
And I always was trying to put in
you know at least one character
who wasn't just oh anglosex, you
know, and so I had the Brazil nanny
and I was like okay, so you know
we'll go from there, you know.
So, and to write and I was actually
approached to write a novel about,
about an undocumented
immigrant teenager.
It's called "Something In Between"
and it's about a Filipino girl
who discovers that her
family is here illegally
and I actually didn't even want
to write it because it's so,
it just reminded me
of being vulnerable.
My family came here in 1985 and
my parents got their green card
and we were here legally, but
back then there was no law
for the adult children, almost
like the dreamers basically
who were brought here as minors.
So, my sister and I were
over the age twenty-one
when my family got their green cards
and there was nothing, there was no,
there was no law that covered
us even though we were brought
here legally.
And so our lawyer said, just wait.
You know, you're just going
to have to wait and I waited,
I was forty when I got my green card
and I was brought here
when I was thirteen.
It was so crazy to me.
So, I didn't want to
revisit those feelings
of being feeling vulnerable,
feeling like I wasn't quite American
on paper, but I was glad that I did
it and I was glad I wrote the book,
so, and I was glad that they
asked for it basically, so.
>> Nicola Yoon: Yeah, I mean so
this is like a topic I won't talk
about for everyone, but
yeah and when I was growing
up I didn't see girls that looked
like me in the books, right.
There were just not that many of
us, and you know, "The Bluest Eye"
by Toni Morrison I think is the
first time that I saw a girl
that looked like me and
I didn't really know
that you could write stories with
like a Black girl main character.
And then one of the movies that I
loved the most is Harold and Kumar,
right this is like, that was
a life changing movie for me,
because it was basically my
college experience right.
So, it's just these goofy kids
who were not stereotypes at all
who they just got to hangout and be
silly and have all the same hopes
and dreams as everyone else and
be sort of dorky in the same way,
and you know, and want better
things in the same way.
So, I mean when I write
books now I mean I write it
against the stereotypes.
I write the people I know,
we live in a diverse world.
The job of writers
is to tell the truth
and that is just the truth, right.
We live in a diverse world.
The world is better and more
beautiful because it's diverse,
so I mean those are the
stories I will always tell
and I didn't want my little girl
to grow up with not seeing herself
in books, and so when
I wrote "Everything,
Everything" I made the main
character look like her.
And one of the best things
that happened was when I went
to the movie set and I took my
little girl and she met Amandla
and literally the first thing
she said to me was like,
"Oh she looks just like me."
I mean and I just cried, right,
I cried a lot on that movie set
let me tell you, because there was
like a moments like that,
but you know, I've now;
now my little girl knows
like she gets to be the hero
of the story right and
everyone deserves that,
like everyone should be able
to see themselves as the hero
and slay the dragon and
get the girl or the boy
and you know be the main
character, so that is my whole deal.
>> Sandhya Menon: Same as them,
I plan to keep writing a
lot more diverse stories.
I think one of the big things
for me too, I have kids as well
and my daughter is eight; she
recently came home and said
that she had drawn a brown princess
and her friend told her
princesses can only be white.
And so, I think I have
to have that conversation
and Nicola recently wrote an
article, a very similar topic
about princesses need to be so many
different colors and it's 20017
and we're still having these
conversations, and the only way
to stop having those
conversations is
to make sure kids are seeing
themselves all different kinds
of kids are seeing themselves
on book covers and TV shows
and storybooks, and so that's why
I'm so passionate about it just
like these ladies and like
I don't plan to stop, so.
[ Applause ]
>> Abby McGanney Nolan: So, I think
we can open it up to questions
if people have questions.
I also, I wanted to,
I forgot to mention
that everyone will be signing
books on the lower level
between two and three; 2 pm to 3 pm.
So, I can't really see very
well, but do you want to start?
>> How do you know when a
book idea is a good one?
>> Melissa de la Cruz: I,
you know, I can feel it.
You know, I remember my
daughter being really interested
in Elizabeth Schuyler and
then I just right then came
up with the title, I said I want
to call it "Alex and Eliza",
because he was never called Alex.
You know, he was either
Hamilton or Alexander, you know,
that Alex is such a casual,
you know, he was not an Alex.
But Alex was my character, you know,
based on this historical figure
and I thought by calling it "Alex
and Eliza" you know I was really
kind of staking my fictional claim
on this story and, you know, I
just thought "Oh my god, this one."
You know, I kind of knew and,
although I didn't know it,
I didn't know it would
be this successful.
We were hoping for one
good week, you know, so.
You never know.
>> Nicola Yoon: I keep an "Ideas"
notebook and I write everything down
and then the ones I keep going back
to over and over and like flushing
out a little bit, are
the ones I tend to write
like either a short story about or
I put; I write really short fiction
to like short stories,
so that's how I know.
Like the ones I keep going back
to and thinking about like a lot
of them fade away and I just like,
"Oh that was just a cool
idea for that moment."
But the ones that I stick to,
are the ones that become books.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yeah, same for me.
I have an "Ideas" folder
on my computer
and usually it's just one
line, but then if I transfer it
to an actually notebook and start
writing more about the characters
than I know there's something there.
>> Thank you.
>> Sandhya Menon: Thank you.
>> Abby McGanney Nolan:
On this side.
>> Hi, so I was just wondering you,
you're in like a very
competitive genre of course,
that's why it has become
so flushed out.
How do you write in like nuance and
new ways, in unique ways about such
like a common phenomenon love?
Like everyone wants to
read about something
that they feel like
only they've felt.
How do you create that
feeling in your works?
>> Nicola Yoon: That's
a great question.
I think, I can't remember who said
this, so I'm not even going to try,
but like fiction is about making
the familiar strange, right?
Or making you feel, you
know, making you feel
like you're the one that's
first ever felt this,
and all love is very specific right?
When you fall in love with someone
that's kind, but everyone's kind
in different ways and
you fall in love with,
particularly if that person is kind.
And I think it's about the
specificity, right, so like for me
when I'm writing two characters that
they're not falling in love generic
and it's not falling in love, right?
They like that person because
they smiled back a certain way
or they're goofy this way
and I mean just the idea
of what is sexy, right?
Like we're both, we're all
going to find three different;
although Jason Momoa I feel
like is universal right?
I was just having this
conversation with someone the Rock
versus Jason Momoa and
I'm like, "Jason Momoa."
I mean like [brief laughter].
Sorry. But, yeah I think
it's about specificity
and I think that's what
makes a difference.
>> Melissa de la Cruz: Oh, yeah,
no I mean, it's interesting
that you said it was a
competitive genre so basically
like how do you stand out, and
you know while it is competitive,
writing itself is not competitive
and art is not competitive,
so the market is competitive but you
know it's really you and the book
and you know I think we all
write you know for ourselves.
I mean, I always, I think the
people make the mistake of writing
for an audience or this kind
of amorphous group of readers.
Like I write to entertain myself.
So if don't like it and
I'm not, I'm not laughing
or I'm not swooning, who is?
You know, so I really, I only care
about my first reader which is me.
So, all these books are for me.
I'm glad you like them too, but.
>> And do you write for your younger
self or always for yourself now?
>> Melissa de la Cruz: I think
I still am my younger self.
You know, I still remember
like everybody I have a grudge
against like it's been thirty years.
Like I remember and they
come and see me on Facebook.
I'm like really?
I remember at lunch.
You know.
>> Nicola Yoon: You do not
want to mess with Melissa.
>> Melissa de la Cruz: Oh, no,
no, no I will come later you know.
>> Thank you.
>> Melissa de la Cruz: Yep.
>> So, I was wondering
like a lot of people have
like a favorite tool they like
to use when they're writing,
like Spotify or Excel or Blue
Maps I was wondering what's yours?
>> Sandhya Menon: I love Scribner.
It's a writing software
that you can install
and like it has these little, I
guess they are like fake index cards
that you can move around
on a corkboard
and there are different folders for
like research and character building
and world building all that stuff,
and it keeps me really
nice and organized.
I love that one.
>> Nicola Yoon: So, I write by
hand into Moleskin notebooks.
I guess my tool is
I get [inaudible].
I write into the notebook.
I eat a lot of kettle corn,
like seriously absurd amounts
of kettle corn and then drink a lot
of tea; those are my, my must haves.
>> Melissa de la Cruz: I
want to learn Scribner.
Like that's been on my
list like, but I can't,
I write on Microsoft Word.
I usually write in silence.
I actually, I had a
day job for nine years.
I was a computer programmer
and I would write my
books, you know, at my job.
And so I find an office environment
really soothing and the sound
of type; people typing on
keyboards and murmuring into phones,
so I'm always joking about
I want to go to like a bank
and just "Can I sit here and write?"
You know, because that's
like my, that's what I need.
But yeah, I write in
silence basically.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Okay, this side?
Who is your favorite
Schuyler sister?
>> Melissa de la Cruz:
Oh, Eliza of course.
No, definitely Eliza.
>> Thank you.
>> So, I'm a writer and I've always
kind of wanted to do something
with multiple perspectives
and so when you do
like dual perspective
writing what's your process?
Like do you alternate or do you
do each perspective all at once?
>> Nicola Yoon: I alternate
because that's how the story
is unfolding in my head.
I don't know if you guys saw Subba
speak earlier, but she was talking
about this too, where the first;
you don't necessarily get the voices
right the first time you're writing,
right.
I mean, everyone always talks
about the big bad first draft
where the book is terrible
and it really is terrible
for the first draft, but you know,
like voice can come in later, right.
You can just have those stories
going, you know, like the mechanics,
the plot just what, what
is actually in the story
and then put the voices in later.
For me, I do practical
things like in "Everything,
Everything" Olly doesn't
believe in grammar, right.
I mean, he like never met a
capital letter that he liked
or a punctuation mark, right.
So, that was a really good way
for me just to get into his head,
because he just never
used punctuation.
Whereas, Maddy was like
very grammatically correct.
So, like physically changing
the text for me helped me get
into their head, and similarly
in Sun Star, you know,
Daniel would write poetry
and Natasha would write
down scientific facts and so that
helped me get into their head.
So, just practical things is a
good way to trick yourself in how
to get into someone's head.
>> Thank you.
>> Sandhya Menon: I like to plot
out the character's arcs first.
So, I get to know them really well
before I start even like writing
and then I just, I don't think
about like oh I need to
switch at this point.
You know, I'll write that
character's point of view
until they're done with that piece
and then so I didn't have like,
you know, I didn't have a
thousand words for Dimple
and a thousand words for Rishi.
I just did it as it felt
natural and let it come
to a natural stopping
point before I'd switch.
>> Melissa de la Cruz:
Yeah, I do both.
I would do alternate and
then I would just get
into somebody's POV really deep
and I would just write the next five
chapters or however much, you know,
in that voice and then go back in
and write the other characters.
So, it would just depend on you
know where I, what my mood was.
Usually in the beginning of the
book, I do a lot of alternates
and then as I'm going to the end,
I just write in one character
all the way through then go back
in and write the other one.
>> Thank you.
>> So, I know when
I write I get a lot
of like influences
from outside sources.
I know you mentioned you got a
lot of inspiration from "Hamilton"
because you're daughter liked
it and you saw the musical,
so how do you take that
time and separate your story
from like the outside inspiration
you get it from to make it unique?
>> Melissa de la Cruz: Yeah,
you know, I mean inspiration
and then execution is different and
you know while I was in inspired
by the musical, I didn't
want to write that story.
Like I wanted to write; I knew
from the beginning I wanted
to write a different story.
I wanted to write a "Pride
and Prejudice" style story.
I wanted to write about the women.
So, I did a lot of research of women
in revolutionary America, you know,
not just a Elizabeth Schuyler's
biography, but Martha Washington's,
Martha Jefferson's, you know,
I wanted to really learn
about you know what did they eat?
You know, what did they wear?
What did they dance to?
You know, it was, it
was amazing to me
that while the American
Revolution was happening in France,
it was Maria Antoinette
in Versailles.
You know, this totally different,
you know, you think like oh my god
that was during the same time.
And, yeah, I don't know.
I think, you know,
it's not interesting
for me to write the same story.
I think what interests me,
you know, I read something
that somebody said once,
I can't remember who,
that all art is a conversation
with each other.
So, it's like a conversation you
know not just with "Hamilton",
but with "Pride and Prejudice"
you know all these other you know
wonderful books that I love and
then from there, you write your own.
You know, I definitely
had my own idea.
You know, one of the big things
in "Hamilton" is Lin-Manuel's
interpretation
of it is Angelica you know
was in love with Alexander
and possibly they had an affair.
You know, he doesn't really make
that clear, but there's definitely,
you know, something there, but
I you know I watched the musical
and then I read all the letters
and I thought there's no
way that they had an affair.
She loved Eliza.
They loved each other so much.
You could never do that
to your sister, you know,
and I was like you know when
you have a; and have a sister
and I was just like, you
know, I just couldn't see it.
I could see loving the same person,
you know, and wanting, you know,
sharing that love,
but not in that way.
That would be such a huge betrayal.
So, in my story that's
not part of it.
You know, Angelica is much
more protective, you know,
and yes she's witty and
clever and all that,
but she's really interested
in status and in making sure
that her life is very
comfortable, you know,
whereas that Hamilton
struggled all the time.
I mean, he wasn't a landowner.
I mean, he, they lived on their
salary you know and whatever she got
from her rich family you
know it was not enough
to support their lifestyle.
You know, even when he died they
were in debt and she had to,
you know, the government you
know helped them you know
with their life basically.
She was like, you know,
you kind of owe us.
So, you know, so that
was really interesting.
I also liked that he was
always in debt as a writer.
I was like, he's a real
writer; always in debt.
>> Nicola Yoon: So, are you
worried about like copying something
because your inspired by it?
Is that where your
question is coming from?
>> No. I kind of like just
like want to make it my own.
It's not like copying it.
>> Nicola Yoon: Right.
>> I feel like at some points it's
too close to where it comes from.
>> Nicola Yoon: Right, yeah.
>> I just want to make
it my own, like.
>> Nicola Yoon: Right.
So, I mean I think that is when
I was like a new writer too,
I would absolutely copy things.
Not like intentionally, right,
but I would get inspired so much.
I would fall in love with
that writing so much that I,
it would take that style.
Sometimes unconsciously
and sometimes you know quite
deliberately and that is okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Nicola Yoon: Like that
is how you learn, right?
Because you, the fact is
you're never going to write
like if Hemingway is your
thing, you're never going
to write exactly Hemingway,
but you can learn a lot
by you know just immersing
yourself in it and trying.
But you, and then that is a
way of finding your own voice.
So, I mean I like my baby
writer self-copied everything
and I learned a ton and
now I write the way I write
which is definitely me, but I
learned that by reading a lot and by
like absolutely imitating
for a longtime.
>> Yeah.
>> Nicola Yoon: So, it's okay.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yeah, me too.
I used to write these
embarrassing stories
that were exactly like
Sophie Kinsella.
Like I mean you wouldn't be
able tell the difference.
And because I love her books
so much and that was okay
and I decided this is going
to be like fan fiction, right?
It's okay.
And so I did a few books like that
and then eventually I kind of grew
out of it and started
doing it my own way,
and I think you'll get there too.
>> Nicola Yoon: Yeah.
Just keep going.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yeah.
>> Nicola Yoon: You'll find it.
>> Thank you.
>> Nicola Yoon: Sure.
>> Is this it?
Hi. I was going to ask a question
about how does your family
and your character's family
influence your character's romance?
>> Melissa de la Cruz: Interesting.
>> Nicola Yoon: I mean,
mine is pretty direct.
Like I am for sure in
love with my husband.
I think he's the coolest
thing on like, you know,
he's just the best boy on earth.
So, like a lot of our
conversations are in my books,
like Olly hates the ocean.
He's terrified of it.
My husband grew up in
southern California
and is terrified of the ocean.
Like in the story, like there's
an entire conversation in the book
that is probably verbatim
from our conversations.
So, I, but because my
characters fall into,
they fall in love just by talking.
It's not so much the physical,
although there's a lot of kissing,
but they really like each
other's brains and so a lot
of that is in my books, talking.
>> Melissa de la Cruz: Yeah, you're
all in love with our husbands.
I mean, you know, and I
mean you write what you know
and like you said, like that
conversations are verbatim, totally.
You know, I totally steal from our
life and I put it in the books,
and I like you know I mean,
he's the guy I know the most,
you know, I know him so well.
So, you know a lot of my
male protagonies are based
on certain aspects of his character
in the way he reacts to things,
you know, you can tell him he knows.
He's like, it's all about me.
But, you know, funny
my family though,
because I've written two
books about Filipino families.
I have a book called "Fresh
off the Boat" which was based
on our immigration story.
It's about a family that
moves from the Philippines.
I wanted to set in the
80s, but they said no,
so it's set in the current time.
And my daughter read it and
you know she wanted to know
who all the characters were and the
only people who are not in my books;
my mom and my dad are in that
book, but I changed the siblings
because my siblings were like
never, ever write about us.
Never! So, they are
not in it anywhere.
You know, because they
know what writers do,
so they don't want any part of
that and I have to respect that.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yeah, same for me.
I love the idea of
like selfless love.
I think my husband is
really good at that.
Like just putting my needs over his
and just thoughtfully doing these
things and I love that and so
in my books I'm, you know,
this one and the future ones,
I always like to have scenes where
somebody does something really nice
for the person they
love and the person
who they love doesn't
necessarily know about it,
but it's just like a very
generous and sweet thing, so yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> Sandhya Menon: Great.
>> Hi. So, as an aspiring writer
I always have like one scene
that I really, really want to write
and how do you build-up
to that in romance?
Because I know romance is a lot
of little things that build-up
to like a climax; how
do you build that?
>> Melissa de la Cruz:
That is a great question.
>> Sandhya Menon: I like this idea
of candy bar scenes and I get this
from a writer called Holly Lisle,
but she talks about candy bar scenes
which are just like you
brainstorm these scenes
that you're really excited
to write and it doesn't have
to be the huge ultimate
climatic scene.
It can be just little
things along the way
that you feel would be just fun
to write as a writer, you know?
And so, those are the
ones that I plot first
and that gets me really
excited and usually I will start
to see a pattern form like, oh
this is how this book is going
to play out, or the love story
is going to play out, you know?
And so, that's what I like to do.
Yeah.
>> Nicola Yoon: Yeah, I mean I
think it's a couple of questions
that have sort of led me to think
that you have to actually keep
in mind that books are
made in revision, right.
They really are not
made in the first draft.
I was talking to my friend Subba the
other night and we're both suffering
through our books, and I
said, like we have careers,
because we're good at revision.
That is, like I mean
it's true, right.
I don't have a career because
I'm good at first drafting,
because I am not good at it.
And honestly, most writers
are not good at it, right?
You're just telling yourself the
story, so that scene that you want
to build toward, it might
be the third revision
that you build towards
it correctly, right.
It doesn't happen on
the first draft.
You're telling yourself the
story in the first draft;
it's supposed to be terrible, it
is terrible, suffer through it.
Call your friends, have them give
you chocolate and then be good
at revision, because that's the job
actually is to be good at revision.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> In "The Sun Is Also a
Star" why did you decide
to create the character Irene?
>> Nicola Yoon: You
know, people love Irene.
She comes up a lot.
>> Melissa de la Cruz: I love Irene.
>> Nicola Yoon: So, I can't;
it's a hard question to answer
because I don't want to
spoil what happens to Irene.
But, I will say that one of the
things I really wanted to talk
about in the book is that
we, like as a society,
live these very big lives, like a
very full you know your kids have
to go to school and they have
to have lunch and you have
to have a job and, and you're
on the subway and the person
across the way looks different from
you and you think you have nothing
in common with them and we have
these big very, very busy lives
and we don't have, we don't find
ways to connect a lot and we think
that we're really so different,
but it isn't true, right?
That person next to you or
that stranger that you think is
so different than you, has the
same sort of impulses and dreams.
You have more in common
than you think you do.
And one of the things I wanted
to say with this book is
that if we can all like just
take a breath and see each other
and maybe talk to each other
and be a little bit kind,
we would get to know that we have
more in common than we don't,
and so that's where Irene is from.
Like Irene seems like
a passing character,
but a kind word saves her, right,
and I think that that is true
that we can do that for each
other, for strangers every day,
you can just have a kind word,
"nice tie", "thank you", "please
and hold the door", and you
can change someone's whole day
and their whole life.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Abby McGanney Nolan: We have
time for I think one more question.
>> Nicola, my Book
Club kids love you.
>> Nicola Yoon: Oh, yeah.
>> They would die that I'm here.
>> Nicola Yoon: Thank you.
>> Thank you so much.
>> And, my question is what
kind of research did you do
for "The Sun Is Also a Star?"
>> Nicola Yoon: Let'
see, what's in that book?
Like immigration.
I did a lot of, I wrote a lot
of immigration documents
which is not exciting.
I will tell you it's very boring.
But, you know, the main character,
one of the main characters is
Korean-American and so I'm married
to someone who's Korean-American,
so a lot of that I know just
from because we've been married
for fifteen years, but you know,
I actually had my Korean-American
friends read the book too.
So, I had people read it to make
sure I didn't get things wrong
about like sort of the
Korean-American experience,
but also just like basic things
like "Would have that for breakfast
if you were a Korean immigrant?"
You know, like so I did research
in that way and made sure
that there weren't anything;
there weren't terrible
stereotypes in the book.
So, that's probably the biggest
part of the research I did
for that book is like
trying to get the sort
of Korean-American experience right.
>> Thank you so much.
Thank you.
>> Nicola Yoon: Thank you.
>> Abby McGanney Nolan: Well
thank you so much for coming,
and thank you so much for
talking about your books,
and life, and thank you guys.
Thank you guys.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.